[تصفيق]
اقتدم المعارك في الجبهتين الشرقيه
والجنوبيه لاوكرانيا منذ بدء الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي يحدد خبراء
اوكرانيون نقطه بدايه في الرابع من يونيو
الجاري لكن قراءه فاحصه لخريطه الجبهات
المستعره تكشف ان ما تحققه القوات
الاوكرانيه حتى الان تقدم طفيف في جبهه
خرسون جنوبا حاولت القوات الاوكرانيه
التقدم نحو الضفه اليسرى لنهر دينيبر
مستغله غرق عدد من المناطق بسبب تفجير سدك
خفكار لكنها واجهت قصف الروسيا عرقله
تقدمها اما في زبولوجيا فقالت كييف ان
قوتها تقدمت بمقدار كيلومترين اثنين على
طول الجبهه مع سقوط قتلى وجرحى في سرايا
من الجيش الروسي وتدمير اكثر من 80 اليه
عسكريه لكن التقدم الاوكرانيه هناك يواجه
التصديا روسيا شرسه تعززه المواقع
الدفاعيه والتحصينات التي اعدها الروس على
مدى اشهر من سيطرتهم على المقاطعه في دنيا
شرقا يحتدم القتال في ثلاث جبهات هي مدن
افديفيكا ومارينكا حيث يحاول الروس اختراق
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه في خط التماس
محاولات التقدم الاوكراني وفقا لخبراء
اروس تستهدف التمدد على طول خط من دونيسك
الى وصولا الى بحر ازوف لكن التصدي
الروسيه في هذه الجبهات ابطات تحرك
الاوكراني اما في بخموت فما تزال القوات
الاوكرانيه تشن مزيدا من الهجمات بهدف
اختراق تحصينات القوات الروسيه والالتفاف
عليها وذلك ما حدا بروسيا الى نقل بعض
الوحدات الاكثر استعدادا للقتال الى جبهه
باخموت لمنع الاوكرانيين من تحقيق اي
اختراق حسب معهد دراسات الحرب في واشنطن
فان المستوى الاول من القوات الروسيه
الموجوده على امتداد هذه الجبهات ينجح حتى
الان في صد او ابطاء القوات الاوكرانيه
المهاجمه وذلك ما جعل وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه تشدد على حاجتها الى اسلحه
بمدى 200 كيلومتر لتجاوز التحصينات
الدفاعيه الروسيه
قال نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
في طريقها للحصول على طائرات ستدافع عن
اجوائها ضد الصواريخ الباليسيه الروسيه
ووراء هذه التصريحات رغبه اوكرانيه في
اعاده تفعيل سلاح الجو في الحرب لذا قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خلال منتدى
سام بيتروسبورغ الاقتصادي ان وجود طائرات
اف 16 المتوقع ان يسلمها النيتوليكييف في
قواعد جويه خارج اوكرانيا يدفع موسكو
للنظر في كيفيه ضربها وتدميرها في تلك
القواعد